what's going on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
people love being scared they love being
spooked they love being dragged
and most of all they love being chased
it's why it's one of the most defining
mechanics of any horror game since the
guy with the scissors and clock tower
back in 1995
survival horror is probably my favorite
genre despite
not handling scary games all that well
this is so horrible i'm having such a
horrible time i'm having a bad time
it's the thrill of being able to push
through herring odds that really just
gets my blood
pumping or coming around the corner and
seeing this guy ready to clap right now
it shouldn't be fun and yet for some
reason our brains tell me and many many
others that we just can't seem to get
enough of it and i want to know why
why do we like being chased
so i call the psychologist that's dr ken
carter he's a clinical psychologist and
professor at the oxford college of emory
university and for the past few years
he's been heavily focused
on sensation seekers people who seek
chaos
new experiences being scared that whole
deal he even wrote a book about
it called buzz and he did a pretty solid
tedx talk as well
so there's actually two different ways
you can go about explaining it freud
talked about the part of our id
that loves what's called the pleasure
principle which means it
loves tension reduction so anything that
reduces tension
creates pleasure for us you may have
heard of the death
instinct that a lot of people have sort
of the wish to be dead that comes from
freud's idea of the pleasure principle
so knowing that something's chasing you
that could kill you
creates pleasure for the id in layman
terms
id doesn't actually just stand for a
game development studio
it also stands for our innate
animal-like
instincts so it's the thing that makes
us eat food or identify something we
should be afraid of or
making babies so to be chaste or to be
chasing something
feeds into that rawest form of just
acting on pure
impulse the other side of freud's theory
is the death
instinct which is the idea that people
enjoy experiencing
near death without actually dying so
think about people who enjoy roller
coasters or go bungee jumping
or to tie back to games being chased by
a dude in a fedora
or a tall lady but with a screen between
you
and the danger of it actually happening
the freud theory is one way of
explaining it
the other is the scientific way or
more simply chemicals
and so we have these two different
chemicals in our body that sort of
regulate
stress one's called cortisol which is
sort of a stress hormone that rubs up
our body
and the other one's called dopamine and
dopamine is important for
creating pleasure so when we're being
chased we create
lots of cortisol and lots of dopamine
and depending upon that balance of
cortisol and dopamine
being chased can be really exciting and
fun because it creates that biological
sense of pleasure
so if things like scary games stress you
out well it's because your brain
produces a lot of cortisol which causes
that
tensing up sort of stressful feeling and
also
another perfect explanation as to why i
reacted the way i did
to five nights at freddy's vr
modified cortisol overload oh
that was horrible now if you walked away
from being scared with the intention of
doing it again because apparently
you had a good time there's nothing
wrong with you that's just the dopamine
talking which is the opposite
of the stress chemical and like all
things it comes with a balance
some people who produce less cortisol
will deliberately seek out
stressful situations to get that
chemical balance to feel that excitement
it might even be a way to explain why
some people just prefer to play games
on easy mode there's nothing wrong with
it but they just
might be stressed out if they did
anything higher than that or
why some people just prefer super hard
games and find really easy ones to be
exhaustingly boring now initially when i
first started researching this whole
thing
it doesn't take long to do a quick
search on why people get scared and find
several sources that just say the
adrenaline rush
which has some of the exact same
chemicals that ken was referring to
like cortisol and dopamine but is that
really just it
are we just feeling little tiny
adrenaline rushes that make us excited
well ken says it's a little bit more
complicated than that
i was talking with will gab he's a ice
climber he's a very first person to
climb
up niagara falls when it was frozen
and he said that adrenaline is a lousy
drug
because it's linked with that cortisol
like he said if i just wanted adrenaline
i would just run
back and forth in the street the
adrenaline sort of gets in the way
of you being able to do really detailed
stuff
because it's linked with that sort of
fight flee or freeze response that
people experience
it's why you can't push the right
buttons to be able to escape
things in in those in those games and so
the
right amount of sort of calmness in
chaos
in order to experience that pleasure is
probably what more people
are about than just their sort of heart
beating and feeling stressed out it's
more complex than just being an
adrenaline junkie
and the funny thing is that a lot of
those high sensation seekers produce
less adrenaline than average and low
sensation seekers
because their body doesn't identify
those things as as being
dangerous and stressful and so they're
just experiencing
that that dopamine that sense of
pleasure which is sort of what they're
after
in the in the first place clearly i
don't like being scared in games
but i do like the ability to fight back
if i'm terrified
if i have no means of protecting myself
my cortisol goes into overdrive and my
dopamine puffs into a smoke and i lock
all up in a way
mr x and lady demetresque are kind of
like
embodiments of cortisol and me having an
arsenal or gun
kind of represents that dopamine to
level it all out the fight
is vital to the chase it's the
opportunity to
possibly overcome something terrifying
or as ken puts it because he's like
smart
and educated emotional regulation
you have to be able to control your
emotions in order to do well in the game
it's not just sort of running away and
avoiding stuff
you have to sort of know what's in your
arsenal how to use it how much health
you have left
and if you just get swept up into the
chaos of the
fear then you're not going to do well
and so that ability to regulate your own
emotions
is something that a lot of people who
are high sensation seekers
really love to do whether it's fear or
anger or whatever and what you're sort
of focusing on
is the ability to control your own sort
of anxiety
or fear in order to do well in the game
and that
that right there that's my high that's
the good
pump that emotional regulation right
into my veins
so does knowing all this explain
people's obsessions with being chased or
people like lady dimitrovsk sort of
i'm not gonna go into the obsession part
of it but we all know it's because she's
got a wonderful smile and a big ol
personality way long but i feel like i
at least understand myself
a little better and why we may
instinctively just enjoy
the thrill of being chased and scared
and most importantly
my new favorite drug emotional
regulation
you may not at all be into scary games
and that's fine
everyone's different take ken for
example that dude has dedicated his work
to understanding sensation seekers
and he couldn't even watch the trailer
for resident evil village
i will not be playing it oh you should
it's a real rock i've watched 10 seconds
of the link you said and i'm like
nope it looks terrifying he may not be
playing
that game but i sure as hell will be
[Music]
you